so last week we already discussed the
story of republican uh senator
from texas ted cruz fleeing the united
states for mexico with his family when
power outages
and major storms hit texas and ted cruz
who vote
formerly voted against hurricane relief
funding for hurricane sandy in new york
and new jersey
wanted immediate emergency funding for
what happened in texas
he asked for that funding hypocritically
and then fled
to cancun mexico to go to the beach now
because of the uproar
that it caused he cut his trip short and
flew
back to texas not even 24 hours later
and there are endless calls for him to
resign and you just have to see how
fox news covered it to understand how
these reactionary right wingers end up
in seemingly alternate universes
imaginary alternate universes i think
it's important to say
it was a combination of pretending it
wasn't happening
what about ism and pretending that it's
just no big deal so let's look at some
examples here
first here is fox and friends defending
ted cruz and saying yeah but what about
andrew cuomo
55 seconds and by the way chris cuomo
who was allowed to interview his brother
in times of good
back in the old he's not allowed anymore
he's calling on ted cruz to resign
right and yet not a word about his
brother who's who's got
the scandal on his hands it is an
amazing double standard it exposes
exactly who they are the pr
department of the democrat party uh
they're going after ted cruz because
he's been an effective
consistent conservative for years he may
have made the wrong call he acknowledges
that
but the media well they they they show
who they are every time
it does look a little lopsided over on
abc
all right i don't even know why steve
ducey
is talking about abc there i maybe i it
looked to me like pete heg seth was
attacking
cnn maybe i missed something earlier
about abc
i'm not sure but of course the playbook
is
ted cruz did something completely
indefensible and pathetic and
humiliating
well attack the media attack cnn
attack andrew cuomo attack attack chris
cuomo
but hold on this is about ted cruz why
are we talking about those other people
other approaches included coming up with
long forgotten scandals to resuscitate
like for example they went back to
hillary
they put up a headline on fox news about
quote
media and political elite mock trump
supporters
with a picture of hillary clinton
from a speech she gave in new york city
five years ago in 2016. this is not a
joke
they actually covered that as the ted
cruz scandal was on fire it reminds me
of the scene
from the movie the naked gun where the
great leslie nielsen
is saying nothing to see here please
disperse
as a building is exploding behind him
that's actually what they were covering
as everybody else was covering
the disgusting disaster of the absence
literal absence from country
of texas leadership during their storms
and power outages
and then while every network was
continuing to cover what was going on in
texas and what was going on with ted
cruz
fox news decided to run an explosive
story
about bill de blasio the new york city
mayor
supporting outdoor socially distanced
dance performances in new york city
during the pandemic okay so
that's fox news's coverage of ted cruz
on fox news now
understand that some other networks and
some other right-wing shows
and other right-wing media outlets they
didn't even talk about it
at all fox and friends went in on
defending what ted cruz was doing
that's one approach but there were many
who were just talking about other things
they were talking about
you know joe biden and his dog which we
will get to a little bit later
and all sorts of other non-stories and
we
are seeing it before our very eyes in
real time
the sort of fermentation of
germination of maybe what is likely to
be
the approach from right wing media for
the next four years and we've we've
predicted it
we weren't unique in predicting it that
right-wing media was going to be
particularly crazy and weaponized in
part because
you have more rep competition right now
in this right-wing media space than you
had four years ago
for who can do the most cartoonish
crazy coverage to get away from
criticizing anything the right does
or to find new ways to criticize
anything joe biden does and we are
seeing it and we're going to have some
more examples a little bit later
but let's now get to an incredible
interview
that ted cruz gave to sean hannity and
that's what i want to discuss next
if you ever feel like you just don't
have enough time to read all the books
you want to read
you have to check out one of my favorite
apps called blinkist blinkist takes
thousands of popular nonfiction books
and distills each one down into an
e-book or
audiobook that you can get through in
just 15 minutes where you're getting all
the key takeaways from the book
just imagine how you'll be able to
expand your horizons and knowledge
by being able to soak up all of the
important
insights from 10 different books in an
afternoon obviously it's perfect for
exposing yourself to a new book
you otherwise wouldn't have time for or
you can use it to revisit a book you've
already read
or use it to preview a book before you
buy the full version and read it
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription
is only about eight bucks a month and
you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get twenty five percent off a
subscription when you go to blinkist.com
pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video